okay jess i want to start with an
experiment where
we swap tick-tock login information to
see just how different our feeds
actually are i don't know what it's
going to reveal about me
i do wonder how different it's going to
be nurse turns into a hot lady
okay so i just got literally the male
version of that
on yours look oh my god
male nurse female nurse
just there's so many animals on yours
list of underrated horror movies i would
never get that i've never seen this
push-up challenge
yeah i think tick-tock recognized that i
would prefer a funny version
of this because it recognized that i
share a sense of humor with this person
in indonesia
tick tock's frictionless personalization
is what made the app an instant success
around the world
but now that global success is crashing
into international politics
putting tick tock in the middle of a
worldwide battle
over how open the internet should be
president trump threatening to ban
tick-tock in the united states as
microsoft is hoping to acquire it
i think chinese tech companies
traditionally have really struggled to
get a cultural foothold
in the u.s because the culture is just
so different
that's eugene way a tech product
executive who's written about how tick
tock which is owned by a company called
bite dance
became the first globally successful
chinese app
how they did it all comes down to design
when you first open up tick tock you
don't have to follow anyone or tell the
app about your interests
or even choose what to watch it shows
you a video and the only decision you
have to make
is how long you watch it so if you look
at the history of
social media most of the giants
in social networking today started by
having
people essentially build up a social
graph
from the bottoms up a social graph is
the web of accounts you follow
and it determines most of the content
you see on facebook
twitter instagram and snapchat the
problem with that approach is that it
can feel like
work building up a social network takes
time you're not necessarily going to
like
every post from the accounts you follow
and it's hard to find accounts that you
would like
but don't know about tick-tock took a
different approach
it bypasses the social graph and instead
builds an interest graph by
watching you interact with videos tick
tock isn't the first platform to do that
it's basically how youtube works too
but because tic tac videos are less than
60 seconds long
you watch more of them which means more
data people
talk about the tick tock algorithm as if
it's a magic piece of software that is
just
miraculously better than every piece of
software
out there but the truth is it's not
necessarily the algorithms themselves
have gotten
that much better but if you massively
massively
increase the training data set that you
train the algorithm on
you can achieve really amazing results
and that's why
i think a lot of people will describe
the algorithm as eerily
accurate eerily personalized tick tock's
interest graph introduces you to
like-minded people
and because the videos are off in music
or meme based rather than language based
you may find that some of those
like-minded people live on the other
side of the world
they might be a dancer in nepal a family
in mexico
or kids in the uk or this guy
as long as the algorithm predicts that
it'll entertain you
and so in that way the tick tock
algorithm kind of allows
bite dance to gain traction
in markets all over the world
with languages that they don't
understand subcultures they don't
understand
ticktock's global appeal enabled it to
reach a billion users faster than the
other social media giants had
but it also set the app on a collision
course with a different trend
the rise of internet nationalism india
is banning
tiktok and dozens of other chinese apps
australia has cited concerns about
national security so to have south korea
president trump issued executive orders
that would ban tick-tock
and messaging app wechat from operating
the us in 45 days
bike dance is based in china which means
it's subject to surveillance by a regime
known for censorship human rights abuses
and cyber espionage
but tick tock says they've never
provided any u.s user data to the
chinese government
for his part president trump has hinted
that this is actually about getting
revenge for the coronavirus
yes why why would you ban it well it's a
big business
china look what happened with china with
this virus what
they've done to this country and to the
entire world
is disgraceful but whatever the
motivation the us targeting a globally
popular app
is a big deal because it throws a wrench
into one of the biggest debates
over what the internet should be a new
america foundation report plots that
debate along a spectrum
of how open the internet is within a
country so
on the one hole we can visualize the
free and open model so that's the
democratic model
very little state involvement in
internet content
as the original home of the internet and
many of the world's biggest tech
companies
the us has traditionally advocated for
the free flow of information online
the opposite end of the spectrum is what
we see in countries like china where
there is heavy state involvement in
content where
they do go to internet companies and say
you have to censor
all these keywords you have to censor
all these foreign websites
china's great firewall famously blocks
sites like google youtube
facebook twitter wikipedia netflix
whatsapp
and many western news outlets but it's
not just china anymore
what we see in the middle are countries
who
i think are going to play a pivotal role
going forward
in this global scale tipping we see
according to analysts surveyed for this
report many of these countries shifted
towards less openness between 2014
and 2018. in 2019 russia moved to build
an internet that is isolated from the
rest of the world
following years of increasing government
censorship turkey has been blocking some
news websites and
recently passed a law giving the
government sweeping powers over social
media
and india the world's largest democracy
leads the world in deliberate internet
shutdowns
turning off the internet is becoming a
defining tool of government repression
by the government ethiopia
liberia venezuela and kazakhstan
as governments decide that a world wide
web doesn't suit their interests we end
up with a fractured internet what some
call the splinternet
where national borders increasingly
dictate what information people can
access online
now it's up to democratic countries to
reimagine an open internet worth
fighting for
instead the us is threatening to ban a
platform used by millions of americans
the u.s benefits from having
technological leadership it benefits
from promoting
a democratic internet model and
contesting authoritarianism and so
abdicating leadership on that front is
not good
in the own interests of the us either
tiktok created a uniquely international
platform but it emerged onto an internet
that wasn't quite ready for it
it arrived in the midst of rising
nationalism from a country that has
never respected internet freedom
so now it's forcing the issue when
authoritarian states assert control over
online speech
should the u.s respond by doing the same
thing
[Music]
you